so it says something about him and of
course that scene also says something
about
robert i never thought of it that way
that's but
someone else is joining the call hey
this is brandon
i am still working on skyward
number three we came up with a name it's
going to be announced eventually
uh brandon i didn't think you'd be
joining us a lot of people are
excited and eager about that we're kind
of in the middle of an interview here if
um
if you don't mind chatting with us
afterwards i think you need to uh
be very careful what is there something
wrong are you upset with brandon
this is a big one skyward three is done
are you
writing right now there may be forces at
work here that we don't
entirely understand can brandon keep
going on this
and not get distracted by something else
shiny maybe you and george can
collaborate and make a game of thrones
spin-off i'm co-authoring those um with
jancey a uh good friend of mine and an
excellent writer so you're just
taking over george's series now it's a
foolish thing to do look there's got to
be something that both of you can agree
on uh people have really liked our socks
and they are really nice socks
wait someone else is trying to join the
call
yay me oh god